안녕하세요
bsn 사옥에 오신 것을 환영합니다
저희 bsa는 서울시 강남구 청담동에
위치하고 있습니다
[음악]
우리가 하고 있는 일은 빌딩과
고급주택 중개 건축 설계 종합건설
빌딩 관리 교육 콘텐츠 제작 등
부동산과 관련된 서비스를 최고의
수준으로 고객분들한테 제공하고
있습니다 우리는이 공간에서
기존의 전통적인 방식을 벗어나
매일같이 혁신적으로 도전하고 있습니다
[음악]
자 그럼 지금부터이 공간을 소개합니다
지금 있는 이곳은
bsn의 포토스팟입니다 내방객이
방문해서 촬영을 하거나 구성원들이
축하할 일이 있을 때 이곳
포토스팟에서 사진 촬영을 합니다
그리고
매 목표를
종이에 적어이 나무에 걸어둡니다네
여기는 휴식공간입니다
직원들이 차를 마시거나 간단하게
식사를 할 수 있는 공간입니다
좁은 공간이긴 하지만 많은 직원들이
만족해하며 사용하고 있습니다
네 여기는 층고가 4m로 높은 층고를
자랑하고 있습니다 많은 인원들이
여기서 업무를 보거나 때때로 전체
회의를 진행하기도 합니다 어떻게
중계를 할 것인지
어떤 서비스를 제공할 것인지 방법을
구축하는 등 모두
매일같이 연구하며 성장해가는 곳이기도
합니다
외근이 많은 업무 특성상
좌석은 자율 좌석대로 이용하며
사용하고 있습니다
이곳 역시 많은 인원들이
근무하고 있는 공간입니다 그리고
폴딩도어로 외부의 테라스가 있어서
많은 개방감을 주었고 그리고 바닥은
콩자별로 마감이 되어 있어 마치
카페에서 근무를 하는듯한 느낌을
주기도 합니다 최근에는
웹드라마도 촬영해서
업무 외에 공간 활용도가 굉장히 높은
공간이라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다
[음악]
네이 공간은 제가 업무를 보는
공간이자 유튜브 촬영을 하고 있는
스튜디오 공간입니다
책장에는 그동안 집필한 책들과 상패
인터뷰했던 기사와 매년 목표 및
계획을 적어 붙여 두었습니다 가장 잘
보이는 곳에 두고 아침마다 보면서 저
스스로 나태해지지 않기 위한 오래된
습관인데
실제로도 효과가 좋습니다
4층 회의실은 총 4개의 회의실이
있습니다 3 4층을 합쳐서 총
10개의 회의실을 많은 분들이
이용하고 있습니다
특히
4층 메인 회의실은 주로 중요한
미팅이나 계약 등이 이루어지고
있습니다
고객의 편의를 생각한 넓은 테이블
대한민국 주요 빌딩들이 정리된 책
창문 너머는 초고가 주택과 빌딩들이
보이는 것이 2회실의 특징입니다
고객과 함께 보는 오브 컬렉션 tv는
압도적인 입체감과 생생한 사운드의
역할로도
훌륭하지만 이렇게 tv를 보지 않을
때는 아름다운 조형물 느낌을 주기도
합니다
앞으로 도이 공간에서 좋은 일들이
많이 이루어졌으면 좋겠습니다
흔히 대한민국에서 가장 비싼 부동산을
이곳에 올라오면 보실 수가 있습니다
dsn은 대한민국 최고가 되겠다는
꿈을 가지고이 공간에 있습니다
앞으로 bsnl 많이 응원해 주시기
바랍니다이 영상을 즐겨 보셨다면
구독과 좋아요
눌러주시면 감사하겠습니다
감사합니다
[음악]